la mort de Robert badenter me submerge
d'émotion je l'ai connu j'ai été amené à
le le voir à plusieurs reprises et je
pense que
c'est c'est un monument qui disparaît et
peut-être plus qu' monument c'est une
conscience c'est vraiment une conscience
qui disparaît parce que je pense que
quel que soit le la fonction qu'il a
exercé que ce soit à travers son métier
d'avocat que ce soit à travers son rôle
comme garde des saut avec l'abolition de
la peine de mort la dépense de la
dépense de L'Indép de la justice la
dépense la défense des grands principes
constitutionnels quand il était
président du Conseil constitutionnel ses
responsabilité politique quand il était
sénateur je pense que véritablement ça
ça a été une une conscience à tous
égards et qui en plus moi pour ce qui me
concerne a toujours su rappeler les mots
qu'il fallait chaque fois que
l'indépendance de la justice était
menacée c'est une grande perte pour
notre pays